buonasera
oggi vi parlo di intelligenza
artificiale e vi voglio convincere che
in realtà anche se questo termine evoca
delle immagini dei pensieri collegate a
film di fantascienza in realtà
l'intelligenza artificiale è già nella
nostra vita di tutti i giorni
secondo il tema di questa giornata già
noi condividiamo la nostra vita di tutti
i giorni con l'intelligenza artificiale
qui ci sono solo alcuni esempi ogni
volta che paghiamo con la nostra carta
di credito c'è un algoritmo tipico
dell'intelligenza artificiale che
controlla se quella transazione può
essere fatta o meno ogni volta che
usiamo il nostro navigatore c'è un altro
algoritmo di intelligenza artificiale
che trova il cammino più breve da dove
siamo dove vogliamo andare
ogni volta che usiamo la nostra posta
elettronica l'intelligenza artificiale
ci aiuta a rimuovere a non far pervenire
nella nostra inbox tutti quei messaggi
che non ci interessano
ogni volta che usiamo la nostra macchina
fotografica se inquadriamo il viso di un
nostro un'altra un'altra persona
vediamo un quadratino verte intorno
perché c'è un modulo della macchina
fotografica che riconosce i visi se
abbiamo un iphone ne usiamo siri
volgiamo colloquiare consigli e fare
domande essere compresi e di solito
anche avere delle risposte di buona
qualità
ogni volta che usiamo google o bing o
qualsiasi altro motore di ricerca
anche lì le risposte che ci vengono date
vengono fornite da un algoritmo basato
su tecniche di intelligenza artificiale
ogni volta che compriamo degli oggetti
sul web usando amazon o qualunque altro
sito per comprare noi non lo sappiamo ma
dietro tutta questa azione di
compravendite di ricevere i pacchi ci
sono delle intere i magazzini
completamente automatizzati come questi
che vedete qui di amazon dove dei robot
gestiscono completamente il magazzino
per decidere che pacchi matt che cosa
mettere dentro i pacchi e dove spedirli
anche sulle cose
nella vita di tutti i giorni in realtà
c'è l'intelligenza artificiale come nei
robot che sono andati su marte e che per
vari anni sono riusciti a fare varie
attività molto interessanti su marte
spedirci dei dati indietro per conoscere
meglio quel pianeta
loro sono riusciti a farlo anche in modo
parzialmente autonomo senza dover
ricevere sempre i comandi dalla terra e
questo appunto basandosi solo
intelligenza artificiale
l'ultimo esempio è quello dei
suggeritori che noi normalmente
riceviamo tutti i giorni quando andiamo
su web usiamo i social media
se noi compriamo qualcosa sul web o
anche solo lo cerchiamo su un motore di
ricerca
vedrete che subito dopo vi arrivano
tantissimi suggerimenti di cose simili
che forse vi potrebbero interessare e
anche questi chiamati sistemi di
raccomandazione sono basati
sull'intelligenza artificiale
quindi in realtà la nostra vita e per
vasata dall'intelligenza artificiale e
noi veramente condividiamo funzioniamo
viviamo insieme all'intelligenza
artificiale in generale chiamiamo
intelligenza artificiale noi scienziati
qualunque attività di un computer che
noi normalmente assoceremo a un certo
livello di intelligenza in un umano
partiamo un po dall'inizio una
brevissima storia di un minuto
dell'intelligenza artificiale
il termine è stato coniato nel 1956
quando un gruppo di scienziati tra cui
questi cinque signori che qui sono
ritratti 50 anni dopo quel momento hanno
deciso di riunirsi di passare un mese
insieme d'estate per fa per discutere
insieme di come rendere i programmi dei
computer più intelligenti più in grado
di fare cose che normalmente farebbe un
umano ea quell'epoca si focalizzavano
solo su alcune cose per esempio su
aspetti di tipo matematico come la
possibilità per un computer
autonomamente di riuscire a definire
anche a provare dei nuovi teoremi
matematici cosa che normalmente farebbe
invece un umano e non un computer da
quell'epoca questo signore qui con la
la maglia rossa e quello che ha coniato
il termine intelligenza artificiale
durante quell'incontro si chiama john
mccarthy
da quell'epoca questa disciplina
l'intelligenza artificiale ha avuto una
storia molto altalenante per molti molti
casi in molte volte nel tempo ha avuto
delle grandi visibilità delle grandi
promesse delle grandi prospettive e poi
spesso queste sono state seguite da
delle calate di interesse perché queste
promesse non sono state completamente
mantenute quindi questa storia
altalenanti ha continuato negli anni ma
quello che è diverso adesso che sembra
essere diverso che c'è una convergenza
di vari fattori e poi cercheranno di
dirvi in alcuni che permette di
convincerci che adesso questa grande
visibilità e dell'intelligenza
artificiale questa grandi promesse che
ci sono adesso non saranno seguite da
una delusione successiva ma invece
potranno andare avanti con risultati
sempre più eclatanti
questi signori all'inizio erano molto
ottimisti pensavano che nell'arco di
dieci anni per esempio si sarebbe potuto
costruire un programma che potesse
vincere a scacchi contro un umano
pensavano che in vent'anni si sarebbe
stato un programma che sarebbe stato in
grado di effettuare quasi tutte le
attività che un umano se effettuare ma
chiaramente questo non è successo tutto
ora non c'è nessun programma che sa
effettuare tutto quello che saprebbe
effettuare un umano anche mediocre e per
vincere a scacchi contro un umano però
ci siamo riusciti e questo per quello
abbiamo dovuto aspettare non solo dieci
anni ma molti di più questo è successo
solo nel 1997 quanto un programma
chiamato deep blue è costruito scritto
dall ibm ha vinto contro il campione del
mondo di scacchi di quell'epoca garri
kasparov questa è un'immagine dove
vedete che un po disperato e
e quella partita dove deep blue ha vinto
contro casco lo è stata effettivamente
una pietra miliare è stato molto
scioccante per molte persone perché noi
normalmente associamo un livello di
intelligenza molto alto in un umano che
sappia giocare bene a scacchi quindi il
fatto che un computer potesse vincere
contro il migliore umano che sapeva
giocare a scacchi
era veramente una cosa pensata come
straordinaria
in realtà poi analizzando bene le cose
questo risultato non era poi così
straordinario perché è vero che noi per
giocare a scacchi bene abbiamo bisogno
di tanti aspetti di intelligenza come
l'intuizione la capacità di fare
analogie la capacità di capire
all'avversario insomma tanti aspetti
anche sociali della nostra intelligenza
che il computer non ha però dalla sua il
computer ha altre caratteristiche molto
importanti per saper giocare bene al
calcio che sono la grande potenza
computazionale che cresce
esponenzialmente negli anni e che anche
a quell'epoca con i grandi calcolatori
mainframe che aveva l'ibm ha potuto
permettere al computer di analizzare
molto in profondità alle mosse le
contromosse degli avversari molto più di
quanto un umano potesse fare anche il
migliore umano che sapeva giocare a
scacchi
questa grande potenza computazionale
quindi ha permesso al computer di
compensare la mancanza di aspetti di
intelligenza umano che invece noi usiamo
per giocare bene a scacchi ibm è una
società che non è nuova a grandi sfide
nel campo dell'intelligenza artificiale
questa è una di quelle
ma recentemente proprio durante questi
ultimi anni dove c'è stata una grande
visibilità di accelerazione dei
risultati dell'intelligenza artificiale
recentemente l'ibm anche dimostrato che
un computer può fare di più che
semplicemente vincere un gioco contro un
umano e nel 1000
2011 infatti un altro programma scritto
sempre da dei ricercatori dell'ebm ha
vinto contro i migliori campioni umani
ha un gioco televisivo che c'è negli
stati uniti che si chiama jawbar di
questo gioco è molto semplice del saper
giocare bene al gioco bisogno
semplicemente a rispondere a tantissime
domande su tante categorie della
conoscenza umana e non solo però bisogna
saper rispondere bene e quindi per saper
rispondere bene bisogna saper leggere
tanta informazione testuale assimilarla
capirla capirne il significato e fare
possibilmente collegamenti tra tutti
questi libri che si leggono e quindi già
questo un risultato entusiasmante che un
computer potesse effettivamente prendere
questa tutta questi testi informazione
testuale capirle verificato e collegare
le cose tra loro ma non solo per giocare
bene bisogna anche saper valutare quanto
si è preparati in una certa categoria di
domande perché durante il gioco a un
certo punto bisogna scommettere parte
dei soldi che abbiamo accumulato che si
saprà rispondere bene alla prossima
domanda in una certa categoria quindi
bisogna saper valutare quanto si è
preparati per poter rispondere alle
domande successive e tra anche qui di
chiaramente questa è una parte
fondamentale del gioco perché se non si
scommette bene nel momento giusto la
quantità giusta chiaramente si può
perdere anche se in effetti si è
preparati e quindi questi due aspetti
hanno dimostrato che anche un computer
come watson che alla fine poi ha vinto
questo incontro questi due campioni
umani in grado di raggiungere questi due
modalità di ragionamento assimilazione
di grande quantità testuali per saper
rispondere bene alle domande ma anche
valutazione di tipo anche pro
possibilistico delle possibilità di
rispondere bene alle domande di esempi
di intelligenza artificiale ce ne sono
tanti questo dimostra che un computer sa
capire quello che noi scriviamo ma anche
ultimamente si è capito che un computer
riesce a comprendere e non solo quello
che scriviamo ma anche le immagini che
noi produciamo quella che si chiama la
visione automatica cioè di un computer
che sa guardare un'immagine capire
quello che c'è dentro ha avuto
grandissimi accelerazione ultimamente
qui per esempio ci sono alcune immagini
e le diciture che le descrizioni che
vengono scritte non da un umano ma da un
computer e vedete che sono molto precise
quindi facendoci capire che i computer
sanno vedere quello che c'è in una
immagine che per un computer all'inizio
è semplicemente una sequenza di pixel e
non solo vedere tutti gli oggetti che ci
sono ma anche le relazioni tra loro e
questo chiaramente a grande possibilità
a potere applicativo pensate
semplicemente ad un cieco che riceve un
immagine che può in effetti vederla
questa immagine perché il computer di e
la descrive un altro esempio di grande
sinergia tra tante tecnologie di
intelligenza artificiale quello delle
auto che riescono a guidare da sole nel
traffico senza l'uso di un interno di un
guidatore umano queste sono un vero
concentrato di tecniche di intelligenza
artificiale perché hanno bisogno di
vedere da sole quello che c'è intorno a
loro
i segnali stradali i pedoni le altre
macchine
ma non solo vederle prevedere quello che
questi oggetti e queste persone faranno
e queste auto faranno in futuro e in
modo da poter rispondere con la migliore
azione da intraprendere in risposta a
queste previsioni e devi non strass
essere in grado di reagire molto
velocemente a delle situazioni non
previste e anche possibilmente critiche
in queste sono due immagini una
dell'auto di google o una di quella di
tesla ma ci sono tanti altri
la tecnologia è molto molto vicina per
essere portate sul mercato queste auto e
sicuramente queste auto saranno molto
molto più sicure delle auto guidate da
un umano perché non si stancano non si
addormentano non guidano facendo
parlando al cellulare o parlando con il
passeggero è tutte queste cose che sono
causa di tantissime vittime della strada
quindi spero di avervi convinto che
anche adesso noi siamo immersi in una
società piena di intelligenza
artificiale ma il futuro lo sarà sempre
di più nel futuro noi condivideremo
veramente tutto con questa uso pervasivo
dell'intelligenza artificiale dove noi e
le macchine intelligenti saremo e siamo
tuttora molto complementari abbiamo
delle intelligenze molto complementari
che se riusciremo a sinergicamente co
compenetrare riusciremo veramente a fare
del meglio per la società e per noi
umani non credo che il futuro sia un
futuro dove le macchine intelligenti ci
rimpiazzeranno ma invece dove
amplificheranno l'anno il nostro tipo di
intelligenza per poter arrivare a questo
tipo di futuro però a questa situazione
così ideale
c'è bisogno di dare alle macchine le
possibilità di prendere delle decisioni
autonomamente perché altrimenti non
potranno essere veramente intelligenti
non potranno esprimersi al meglio
e queste decisioni che prenderanno toni
poole mente però bisogna essere sicuri
che le prendano nel modo giusto cioè
bisogna assicurarci che nello sviluppare
nello scrivere il codice per costruire
queste macchine intelligenti
noi dobbiamo assicurarci che loro lo
facciano si raggiungendo gli obiettivi
che noi gli abbiamo dato ma soprattutto
seguendo dei principi etici dei valori
morali che siano allineati con quelli
degli umani e quindi dobbiamo essere
sicuri e tranquilli è solo questo ci
darà la tranquillità per poter dare loro
il controllo di prendere delle decisioni
autonome
questo è l'argomento di un progetto di
ricerca che ho recentemente iniziato che
è stato finanziato da una
la fondazione americana e che comprende
tantissime persone filo anche un
filosofo uno psicologo persone di
informatica persone che hanno lavorato
alla nasa che si occupano di missioni in
situazioni critiche perché pensiamo che
veramente questo sforzo di inserire
dentro le macchine intelligenti principi
etici e valori morali simili a quelli
umani sia necessario uno sforzo
collettivo di tante discipline e
pensiamo di riuscirci chiaramente non
sarà un lavoro che sarà finito una volta
che il nostro progetto sarà arrivato
alla fine saranno bisogno di tantissimi
progetti di tantissimi altri ricercatori
ma siamo veramente ottimisti che questo
possa essere fatto e quando si arriverà
a questo
a questo risultato allora veramente
potremmo dire di essere in una società
dove le macchine e gli uomini si aiutano
l'un l'altro e dove le macchine potranno
anche aiutarci a darci più tempo
effettuando dei lavori che normalmente
noi effettueremo da soli darci più tempo
per noi più tempo per i nostri cari più
tempo per capire noi stessi le nostre
desideri i nostri bisogni e soprattutto
più tempo per capire veramente cosa ci
rende umani
quindi io non sono preoccupata che
l'intelligenza artificiale elimini
distrugga la nostra umanità ma anzi il
contrario
penso che l'intelligenza artificiale ci
aiuterà a capire meglio che cos'è che ci
rende umani
grazie